hello and welcome to math simplified i'm
dr umar malik and in today's video we
will talk about melasma
melasma is a skin condition that causes
patches and spots on the face which are
darker than your natural skin tone
most people get it on their cheeks chin
nose bridge forehead and above the upper
lip
it sometimes affects your arms neck and
back also
in fact melasma can affect any part of
your skin that is exposed to sunlight
that's why most people with melasma
notice that their symptoms worsen during
the summer months
melasma is a very common skin disorder
and the condition is much more common in
females than men
although men can develop it too
according to the american academy of
dermatology 90 percent of the people who
develop melasma are females it's also
called chloasma when it occurs in
pregnant females the word chloasma
basically means the mask of pregnancy
the word melasma comes from the greek
word milas which basically means black
it is not an infection therefore it is
not contagious meaning it does not
spread from one person to another it is
also not due to an allergy and certainly
not a pre-malignant condition
melasma is more common in people of
color and those who tan very quickly but
can occur to anyone
it may occur in any population but it is
more common in asian middle eastern
mediterranean african and brazilian
populations
now let's talk about what is the reason
behind melasma
this is a cross section of the skin
which shows skin cells arranged in
different layers
among these skin cells you can clearly
see a large pigment producing cell that
is known as a melanocyte
these melanocytes have finger like
projections known as dendrites which
extend all over the skin so that the
pigment produced can be evenly
distributed to the skin
melasma develops due to the over
production of melanin by these cells due
to certain factors like excess sunlight
exposure the melanocytes become
hyperactive and start producing
excessive melanin
this causes the development of dark
patches of skin on your face or anywhere
else on the body genetic predisposition
exposure to sunlight including
ultraviolet rays
skin type
hormonal factors including pregnancy
hormonal therapies and the use of oral
contraceptives are the main risk for the
triggers of melasma
additional factors associated with the
development of melasma also include some
cosmetic usage intake of certain
medicines like photosensitizing and
anti-epileptic drugs can cause melasma
several studies suggest that melasma can
also be associated with zinc deficiency
and abnormal thyroid function
change in skin color is the only symptom
of melasma the brown patches don't hurt
itch or physically affect you
the patches are usually an even brown to
gray brown in color and are usually
symmetrical
there are some patterns in which melasma
occurs
common facial patterns of distribution
for melasma include the centrofacial
pattern the malar pattern and the
mandibular pattern the centrofacial
pattern commonly affects the central
part of the face including the forehead
cheeks nose upper lip and the chin area
then we have the malar pattern which
predominantly involves the lateral cheek
areas
we also have the mandibular pattern
which affects the lower jawline
so now we have a brief knowledge of what
melasma is and how it presents let's
talk about the psychological impact of
melasma
multiple studies have documented the
detrimental and psychologically
devastating effects that melasma has on
quality of life
a study of 140 individuals with melasma
from india found that 75 percent of
these people were bothered or frustrated
by the disease most or all of the time
42 of these patients reported that
melasma was associated with depression
embarrassment and had a negative impact
on relationships with other people
the psychological problems can impact
young and old patients alike but the
studies point out that the quality of
life was worse in unmarried female
patients with melasma
melasma is generally diagnosed based on
a clinical presentation or using a
special lamp known as the woods lamp
that uses ultraviolet light for a closer
examination of the skin and classifies
melasma as epidermal dermal or mixed
depending upon the location of melanin
in the skin
in some rare cases where there is a
confusion your doctor can ask for a skin
biopsy which is very small piece of your
skin is taken to make sure that the
brown patches are indeed melasma
the management of melasma is often
challenging with incomplete responses in
many cases and frequent relapses
patients must adopt to a consistent
treatment regime to avoid relapses
patient education and counseling about
avoidance of triggers and risk factors
for melasma and the importance of strict
sun protection during and after
treatment is the key to successful
management of melasma
photo protection is an essential
component of melasma treatment one of
the most important things you can do to
prevent melasma worsening is by
protecting yourself from uv radiation
this means avoiding the sun wearing
white brimmed hat when you are outside
and wearing broad spectrum sunscreen
since uv rays are well known trigger for
melasma and can make hyper pigmented
patches even more dark wearing sunscreen
can help prevent melasma from flaring up
and hyperpigmentation from getting worse
the sunscreen should have an spf rating
of 30 or above with a high uva rating
the higher the spf rating the more
effective the sunscreen will be
protecting your skin from the sun will
also help the medicines used in the
treatment of melasma to have more
effectiveness
since sunscreens and photo protection is
such a broad topic we will talk more
about sunscreens and photo protection in
our next video
now let's look at some of the topical
medications that are used in the
treatment of melasma
for patients with mild melasma doctors
suggest using skin lightening creams as
the first line therapy
skin lightening agents can be basically
divided into two main types
those that contain hydroquinone and
those which do not contain hydroquinone
hydroquinone four percent cream can be
applied to the affected areas once or
twice daily for two to four months and
can be extended up to six months
hydroquinone works by inhibiting an
enzyme that is required in the synthesis
of melanin
non-hydroquinone skin lighteners include
azaleic acid kojic acid and niacinamide
they can be used alone or in combination
with hydroquinone as alternative first
line therapies particularly in patients
who do not tolerate or have a
demonstrated allergy to hydroquinone
for patients with moderate to severe
melasma triple combination cream is used
which contains flucinolone hydroquinone
and tretinoin
flucine alone is a very mild steroid and
tritinoid is a derivative of vitamin a
the cream is applied nightly for two to
four months
it may take several weeks before you see
the results of this treatment so it's
important to follow your doctor's
recommendation even if you haven't seen
any improvement yet
you should keep treating your skin even
after your melasma goes away this will
help to prevent a relapse
it is also important to avoid excessive
sun exposure and to use a good sunscreen
daily this will also help to prevent
melasma from returning
now let's talk briefly about the role of
antioxidants in the treatment of melasma
a randomized double-blinded study was
done by ahmad at all on 66 hispanic
females with melasma to study the role
of antioxidants in the treatment of
melasma
the females were divided into two groups
of 33 females each in the first study
group the females were only advised to
use sunscreen two times a day and in the
second group
in addition to applying sunscreen the
females were also given polypodium
leukotomos extract which is an oral
antioxidant
after a course of 12 weeks the group
with oral poly podium leukotomus extract
resulted in a 28.8
improvement and the group that simply
used the sunscreen resulted in only 13.8
percent improvement in the melanin index
this shows that antioxidants can also
have a positive effect in the treatment
of melasma
now if the creams are not effective in
the treatment of melasma the second line
treatment is used which includes
chemical peels
in this procedure we use products such
as glycolic acid salicylic acid
trichloroacetic acid or jester's peel
chemical peels can improve melasma by
removing the outermost cells of the skin
that contain the pigment
glycolic acid peel is done in a
dermatologist's office and it is a quick
and effective way to rejuvenate the skin
dermatologists use a 30 to 40 percent
concentration of glycolic acid and it
stays on your skin for only two to three
minutes after which it is washed away
chemical peels should be performed by an
experienced practitioner only as
inappropriate peels could make the
pigmentation worse lighten the skin too
much or cause scarring
superficial chemical peels are a
treatment option for patients with
melasma that do not respond to topical
therapies alone
while the term peel makes the treatment
sound quite harsh
it's quite gentle actually you'll feel
some tingling but there's no burning
redness or discomfort
for the next five to seven days make
sure to treat the skin gently do not use
any exfoliation products or devices and
it's very important that you use
protection against uv exposure as the
skin becomes very sensitive after a
chemical peel
lasers and light therapies are the third
line treatment for melasma appropriate
for patients in whom topical treatments
and often chemical peels have failed to
produce adequate improvement
they should be used with great care and
caution particularly in patients with
darker skin to minimize the risk of post
inflammatory hyperpigmentation
some types of lasers remove the outer
layer of skin whereas others target the
pigment producing cells in the skin the
melanocytes
various types of lasers are used in the
treatment of melasma like fractional
lasers q-switched nd yag lasers and ipl
lasers also known as intense pulse light
laser
the success of laser therapy is variable
and there may be risks associated with
the treatment similar to those above
routine approaches for prevention of
relapse involves the aggressive use of
broad spectrum sunscreens as well as
protection from the excessive sun
exposure by using appropriate measures
despite this approach with the
availability of various treatment
options relapses are common relapses
require resuming active maintenance
treatment with azaleic acid kojic acid
niacinamides and retinoids
that'll be all for this video if you're
too stressed about your melasma do
remember
beauty lies in the eyes of the beholder
not in the color of your skin
thank you take care and we'll come up
with a detailed video on sunscreens in
our upcoming videos so make sure to hit
the subscribe button
you can support our channel by becoming
a member on our patreon page all the
links are in the description below